en l'espace de 24 heures volody
mirzelenski pourrait passer du front
ukrainien aux honneurs de Washington
pour sa première visite à l'étranger
depuis l'invasion russe le président
ukrainien devrait rencontrer jobiden et
prendre la parole devant le Congrès
américain mardi volody myersky est allé
prendre le pouls de la situation sur le
front de barmouth laissant entendre
qu'il se rendrait aux États-Unis
nos hommes sont plus courageux mais nous
avons besoin de davantage d'armes
sophistiquées nous allons exprimer leur
reconnaissance au Congrès et au
président américain pour leur soutien
mais c'était n'est pas suffisante on le
voit ici ce n'est pas assez
cette visite interviendrait alors que
les parlementaires américains
s'apprêtent à voter une nouvelle
enveloppe de soutien à l'Ukraine Joe
Biden doit pour sa part valider l'envoi
de système de défense entière aérienne
patriotes selon ce journaliste à la
Maison Blanche se déplacement n'est pas
un autre
s’assurer que l'aide américaine va se
poursuivre alors que le contrôle du
Congrès va passer des mains des
démocrates aux républicain dans les
prochaines semaines c'est aussi un
moment important car l'Ukraine va
bénéficier d'une aide de 45 milliards de
dollars promises pour les prochains
combats
les États-Unis sont les premiers
fournisseurs d'aide à l'Ukraine
Washington adorent déjà donné près de 50
milliards de dollars dont 20 milliards
d'armements ce nouveau volet d'aide
tombe à pic pour Kiev alors que les
combats sans lisent la Russie cible
systématiquement les infrastructures
grainiennes entraînant des coupures de
courant et d'eau le gouvernement
ukrainien redoute par ailleurs une
potentielle ATT virus à partir de la
Biélorussie voisine